at the hospital in kagara
doctors and nurses treat windows
students and teachers
and at the kagara science college
concerned parents gather for news
also in town security stepped up just as
the state government
ordered the closure of schools in those
areas prone to attacks
schools are increasingly targeted as
they offer an opportunity to take many
students hostage
in nigeria there's totally absent
uh absence of lucky government
administration which has become very
difficult for the
locals to have anyone to run to another
thing here
is that uh there is also a
porous border surrounding most parts of
that
area if you look at what is happening
internationally like in places like
china
in cameroon especially in southern
cameroon these countries have not been
able to
hold our the security uh military
onslaught
for too long this is the second major
school kidnapping
in us many months in december last year
gunmen stormed the school and abducted
hundreds of students
in president buhari's home state of
qatar
but six years before that in 2014
in a case that made headlines around the
world more than 270 girls were snatched
from a school in chibok
at least 100 are still unaccounted for
the armed group boko haram claimed
responsibility
and four years after that in neighboring
yoga state the group took more than 100
students from a school in deputy
kidnapping for ransom is now big
business in nigeria from the north down
to
the country south hundreds of nigerians
are kidnapped every week for ransom
and despite military offences against
what officials
are called bandits the problem continues
to grow
on monday 18 passengers were seized
while traveling in a bosnia
aquila not far from where the latest
kidnapping took place
eight have since managed to secure their
freedom
although there are no official
statistics it's estimated
20 million dollars was paid in ransom
money in 2020 to kidnappers
and this in a country africa's largest
economy
while poverty is on the increase
al jazeera abuja